there's always pressure it's just when
do you tune it out
what you guys go over counter no counter
it's not about what you're doing it's
about how you're doing it
so whether that be me studying film
applying to colleges or just studying
for a test like the s.a.t it all comes
from your practice which you've been
doing before
we've done this hundreds of times
ran this thousands of times
the phrase that we use practice how we
play that's pretty much our slogan
whether we're on the field or off the
field
it all starts now so working little by
little to get to that goal and we
practice practice practice so that when
the game comes along you already know
what to expect
you just know what you're going to do
you can go out any day and do the same
thing over and over
[Music]
and it'll happen
you